approval voting the voting system for
multi candidate races races with more
than two candidates which are typical
and say presidential primaries with five
to ten major candidates starting off in
Iowa New Hampshire and those kinds of
races approval voting would permit you
to vote for approve of as many
candidates as you like so if there were
nine candidates in the race the
Democratic primary in New Hampshire in
2008 and you were a liberal Democrat and
you've identified three people as
liberal in the Democratic Party and you
wouldn't have to make an arbitrary
choice of one of the Liberals you could
vote for all three and thereby better
express your preferences so you can do
everything you can under the present
system vote for one candidate if you
have a clear favorite but if you don't
have a clear favorite if you're
relatively indifferent among several
candidates like the Liberal Democrats
you can vote for all of those or if you
despise somebody you can vote for
everybody else
so it gives you great flexibility in
being able to express your preferences
and it's on a ranking system each person
whom you approve of gets one vote and
the person with the most approval wins
the election and we've shown that it
would have major consequences in a race
like the 2000 presidential election
presumably many native supporters would
have also voted for Gore to prevent
their worst choice Bush from winning so
they would have cast to approval votes
some would have bullet voted we say
voted exclusively for Nader and gore
would have of course his exclusive
supporters but it's almost it's quite
clear that a sufficient number of NATO
supporters would have also approved of
gore such that he almost surely would
have won the election in Florida and the
presidential election so it would have
made obviously a difference in that
election and there are many other
examples with significant third or
fourth
party candidates in which the outcome
almost surely would have changed we
can't quite assert that it would change
in the end because when you change the
rules and we're changing the rules by
allowing approval voting the nature of
the campaign would change and we can't
simply extrapolate from the present
campaign but I think there's good enough
information in the 2000 election to say
that under approval voting Gore almost
surely would have won
so besides giving the voter more
flexible options it tends to elect the
strongest candidate overall not the
strongest minority candidate and we have
examples where as significant candidates
on the left or the right a beat out a
centrist candidate a centrist is hit
from both sides so to speak by the left
and right candidates in a three
candidate race and comes in third let's
say so even if there's a runoff which is
sometimes proposed as a solution and
used as a solution to try to find the
strongest candidate the runoff would pit
the left candidate against the right
when it's pretty clear the centrist
candidate in a pairwise contest against
the left candidate would beat the left
candidate a pairwise contest against the
right candidate would beat the right
candidate so it could be to each of his
competitors in separate payer wise
contests we actually have a name for
that candidate in these multi candidate
races he's the corner say candidate
after the maquis de condor say of late
18th century france who proposed this
kind of candidate and showed that one
always doesn't find such a candidate it
almost surely would have liked condors
say candidates winners in these multi
candidate contests so generally in the
United States the contest comes down to
two major candidates in a general
election even an election like the 2000
election but in party primaries when you
get five to ten major candidates
it's often the case that the condor say
winner gets cut out the field is crowded
the centrist to squeeze the strong left
candidate a strong right candidate wins
and it's a disaster in my opinion for
the country
it happened in 1964 when the Republicans
nominated Barry Goldwater an extreme
right-wing candidate lost disastrous
Daly to Lyndon Johnson that year in the
presidential the general election it
happened to the Democrats in 1972 they
nominated George McGovern I kind of foul
left candidate who lost massively to
Richard Nixon that year and that's not
good for democracy because the elections
essentially decided when one party
nominates an extremist against the
centrist of the other and I think if
approval voting were used especially in
primaries it would tend to surface the
strongest candidate in a party and make
the contest much more competitive with
two centrists running against each other
rather than extremists who usually gets
beaten in these kinds of contests so I
think not only does it help the
individual it helps the social choice
the candidate elected making him or her
a much more plausible candidate than a
relative extremists like Goldwater in 64
or McGovern in 72
no I actually think the opposite I think
when you can approve of more than one
candidate you're less likely to vote
strategically if you mean by strategic
voting ignoring let's say a first choice
because he a Nader is out of the running
and voting for a second choice or a
third choice to prevent your worst
choice from winning under approval
voting you can have your cake and eat it
too you can vote sincerely for the
candidate who can't win the Nader and
you can cast a second approve of what a
strategic vote for the candidate who can
can Gore in the 2000 election so I think
it actually minimizes a strategic voting
the two arguments that have been made
against approval voting first that it
would tend to elect the lowest common
denominator the centrist candidate who
tries to be everything to everybody
but I think the candidate is the lowest
common denominator is generally going to
be unappealing to most voters you try to
be everything to everybody you're not
going to be acceptable to very many
people and a good example of a candidate
who would win under approval voting
would be Ronald Reagan Ronald Reagan won
in landslides in 1980 in 1984 he was a
right orient candidate but he was
appealing to a substantial majority in
each election
nobody ever cues Reagan of being weak or
pusillanimous he had strong convictions
and he would have won not only under
approval voting but virtually any other
system so I think that's the kind of
candidate who was generally appealing
maybe right of center or left of Santa
who's going to win it's not always going
to elect the candidate inoffensive bland
who has nothing to say so I think that's
my argument that it wouldn't have that
effect the other argument sometimes made
about against approval voting is that it
would undermine the two-party system
well first of all I think there's
nothing sacrosanct about the two-party
system in the United States most Western
democracies have multi-party systems
and in my opinion they're just as
democratic if not more so than the
United States so I would argue that if
the two major parties Republicans and
Democrats were so Darrel electors to
nominate extremists in the same year
there should be room in the center for a
centrist to come in and win an approval
voting would tend to promote that
rosboroughs an example in 1992 he was a
significant third party candidate who
ran against Bush the father and Clinton
that year and he got 19 percent of the
popular vote almost an all-time high for
a third party candidate if there had
been approval voting he conceivably
might have won because Democrats might
also have approved the Perot he was
liberal on social issues and so my
Conservatives he was conservative on
financial and economic issues now he was
also a little crazy so that dispirited
many of his supporters in the end but a
more credible centrist candidate I think
should have that opportunity to win and
right now our two-party system is pretty
much impregnable under plurality voting
you have to vote for one or the other
candidate you're generally going to
ignore the third or fourth party
candidate so that candidate has no
chance with approval voting you can
afford to vote for additional candidates
and if there's a sufficiently strong
third or fourth party candidate I think
he or she should win